with woe long Fallen Dynasty developer
team ninja feels like it's riffing on a
riff the action game Studio has already
given its spin to the souls-like genre
with the Neo games in wo long team ninja
once again borrows some of the
underpinnings of from software's lauded
series but takes a faster more Ninja
gaiden-like approach it's some of the
same ideas but with a different feel
which will challenge action game fans in
a lot of different ways
okay
Gamespot got an early look at will
Long's playable demo on PlayStation 5
which gives a snapshot of the game's
combat systems a lot of the foundation
will be familiar to souls like fans
enemies hit hard and are tough to kill
often sporting unblockable or
uninterruptible animations whenever you
stop to rest at a checkpoint enemies
respawn forcing you to fight them again
healing is limited to a small set of
flasks you carry and using them takes a
very long time leaving you open to
attack most fights come down to
analyzing or memorizing enemy attack
patterns so you can exploit weaknesses
and avoid taking an abundance of damage
but as mentioned low long takes a much
faster and more aggressive approach to
that Foundation than most other
souls-like games making it most
comparable to something like Sakura
Shadows die twice while long focuses on
Chinese martial arts and thus much of
its gameplay is about Speedy strikes and
redirecting your opponent's Force its
biggest adjustment from similar games
though is that it drops the usual
stamina gauge that dictates how many
moves you can make before you stall out
instead wool long Sports a spirit gauge
which dictates how much you can block or
Dodge as well as special abilities like
martial arts or magical Wizardry attacks
the spirit gauge is less a limitation
than it is a gamble though
the gauge starts at zero in the center
with a negative and a positive side when
you take damage block attacks Dodge or
use special abilities you lose spirit so
the gauge pushes into the negative
if your gauge fully fills up on the
negative side a hit from an enemy will
stagger you leaving you vulnerable for a
long time
conversely though striking enemies fills
up the positive side of the spirit gauge
which allows you to use special attacks
or to dodge and block more with no
penalty so you're rewarded for fighting
aggressively what's more enemies also
have a spirit gauge when they hit you
they gain Spirit while you lose it and
when you hit them they lose Spirit while
you gain it so you're not only rewarded
with more chances to use your abilities
or magic when you lay into a baddie you
also push them closer to being staggered
leaving them open for an execution move
that does massive damage combat then
becomes a sort of tug of war match
between you and your opponent where
you're always paying attention to your
spirit and their Spirit enemies come at
you fast and the best way to deal with
them is to block their blows but you
need to be ready to exploit an opening
where you risk being overwhelmed enemies
also have unblockable critical attacks
that can do major damage if they hit you
but this is where wolong's dodging
mechanics come in under normal
circumstances dodging costs a lot of
spirit more than blocking in most cases
if you dodge at exactly the right time
however you can redirect an enemy past
you or instantly counter them executing
a perfect Dodge on a Critical Strike
does major harm to an enemy's Spirit
gauge while leaving them vulnerable to
your attacks so mastering the timing of
dodging critical strikes is key
[Music]
the tug of war metaphor extends beyond
the spirit system to wo Long's other
major development the morale system it's
a way through which wo long feels like
it's marrying souls-like action game
encounters with rpg-like systems
throughout the game you have a morale
level as do your enemies it's a measure
of confidence and the higher your morale
the more capable you are against foes if
you face an enemy with a lower morale
level you're likely to stop them
opponents with higher morale are tougher
your morale goes up as you defeat foes
so if you run into an enemy with a
higher number than you it's possible to
leave and go take down some lower level
enemies in order to build up your morale
and even the odds morale is fluid for
your enemies just as it is for you
however
if an enemy hits you with a Critical
Strike it'll deal a Blow To Your Health
as well as your morale so mistakes can
be punishing
if an enemy kills you your morale is
reset and that enemy gains a boost in
their morale so you get an incentive to
go get revenge on the foes that beat you
you get a big boost to your morale if
you do so as well as your lost genuine
Chi the currency you use to level up
foreign
s work together to create fluid battles
that are both fast and aggressive and
require you to use your head taking out
a bunch of smaller foes before facing a
tougher leader enemy can give you an
advantage both by raising your morale
and by cutting off bonuses the leader
character gets from their allies there's
also good reason to explore other paths
if you hit an enemy you can't beat
because finding checkpoints where you
can place battle Flags raises the floor
of how low your morale can drop if you
die that way if an enemy kills you less
time is needed to raise your morale so
you can face them again at the start you
can create a character and choose one of
five elements for them to specialize in
each with its own brand of magical
spells and Stat bonuses
as you level up you can choose where to
invest points to change your stats
allowing you to adjust your character to
your play style if you want to favor
defense over attack magic over stealth
or boost your spirit gains you can do so
which gear you choose to equip affects
your Elemental affinities as well you
can have two melee and two ranged
weapons equipped at a time allowing you
to swap between them on the Fly for
different fighting styles you'll also
meet Divine beasts that can help you in
battle once you've defeated enough
enemies with the fire Beast we were able
to do a big hit for massive damage on
enemies with fire lingering on the
battlefield that could continue to
damage them if they wandered into it the
warlong demo culminated in a tough
multi-phase boss fight that really
brought all the systems together in an
extended battle you really get a sense
of how morale and spirit influenced the
game the fight is as much about dishing
out a lot of damage and avoiding attacks
as it is about managing Spirit to make
sure you can deal with the boss's next
round of strikes or push him to the
brink so you can land a powerful
execution
yeah
in truth it wasn't until the boss fight
that I really started to get how woe
long wanted me to play it it's less
about dodging attacks and minimizing
Health loss and more about blocking
staying close to foes and hitting them
hard when the window opens
the Speedy gameplay the variety of
attack options and the push and pull
nature of the spirit system make wo long
feel like a fresh spin on souls-like
games it captures the difficulty and
skill players like about the genre while
pushing a different kind of action game
feel though we haven't seen all of
warlong in action yet team Ninja's demo
does a great job of giving a snapshot of
a tough game that starts at the same
place as other Souls likes and goes in
an exciting New Direction
[Music]